[Musica]
allora io sono belga fiammingo e quindi
vi parlerò in italiano
allora vent'anni fa sono entrato in
quell'edificio verde che vedete qui e li
ospita il museo delle tecnologie
giurassiche di museo of girasse
technology e se sapete tutti che il
giurassico è un era preistorica in cui
il mondo era popolato dai dinosauri
no però questo museo non parla di
dinosauri e non parla neanche di
tecnologia parla lo fa vedere e leggo
una scultura di un papa dentro
l'occhiello di un ago da guardare con un
microscopio un pipistrello incastrato in
un blocco di piombo e quindi invisibile
la corna di una donna inglese e quindi è
difficile spiegare il senso di tutto ciò
e non voglio neanche provarci sta di
fatto che quando esci da questo museo
dal buio da questo museo e rientri nella
luce riverberante della città di los
angeles
sai e senti che il mondo deve essere un
po più complicato rispetto a quella che
viene intorno la strada le macchine
semafori il museo di ha messo in uno
stato di meraviglia che spesso anche uno
stato di dubbio
ho poi saputo che qualcuno scritto un
libro proprio su questo museo e lo
chiama un degno erede del
dei gabinetti delle meraviglie del
cinquecento ebbene anche il cinquecento
tutte era un po difficile spiegare il
senso di tutto che si vedevano 500 tutte
le novità le notizie che arrivavano con
le scoperte nelle americhe e spandeva di
molto l'immaginario collettivo della
gente ha creato una confusione generale
che ha governato l'europa per più di 100
anni e nascevano appunto queste stanze
delle meraviglie
le umbre camerino dove si raccoglievano
proprio di tutto le cose più bizzarre
vere e anche inventate e mentre tante di
queste collezioni alimentavano il gusto
barocco per lo straordinario lo
smisurato altre diventavano strumenti
per lo studio in italia e per questo mi
piace parlare di tutto ciò in italiano
veramente unitario tra leonardo e
galileo il bolognese ulisse oliva andry
aveva uno scopo ben preciso con una sua
collezione voleva voleva sistematizzare
e ricomporre il sapere tramite una
ricostruzione microcosmica del
macrocosmo lanciato appunto scrive con
un certo orgoglio oggi nel mio
microcosmo si possono vedere il numero
di 18.000 cose diverse
veramente esemplari delle specie
prodotte dal grande iddio infatti
per tanto tempo ricondurre tutto a un
unico creatore era l'unico modo di dare
qualche coerenza questo cause meraviglie
ma pian piano le meraviglie dovevano
lasciare spazio ai dubbi su come fosse
stato descritto il mondo nella bibbia e
nei testi classici androvandi vedeva la
necessità di cambiare ed eri con poi il
sapere suo primo lavoro è stato di
dividere i suoi 18 meli 18 mila
esemplari in naturalia e artificialia
quindi cosa è fatto dall'uomo no cosa
farò dare natura e cose fatte dall'uomo
e questo può sembrare banale ma
all'epoca ero era una era un approccio
radicalmente nuovo la realtà un
approccio che poi portata al pensiero
moderno in cui la divisione tra natura e
uomo e poi diventato la divisione tra da
una parte le scienze e dall'altra parte
l'art la regione
la bottiglia la politica eccetera
io sono uno scienziato per il mondo solo
un climatologo e mi è sempre parso utile
vedere i cambiamenti climatici di oggi
nel contesto dei cambiamenti avvenuti in
tutta la storia della terra una storia
lunga quattro e mezzo miliardi di anni
ma guardiamo solo gli ultimi 600 milioni
di anni da quando la vita è migrata
dall'oceano alla terraferma e dai
reperti fossili sappiamo che ci sono
state queste grande estinzione di massa
causate da cataclismi naturali
no impatti meteoritici attività
vulcanica e poi i cambiamenti climatici
che ne erano la conseguenza questi
estensioni massi questi strati di
fossili poi dividere lastre la
preistoria inter e geologiche il
giurassico ricordato il giurassico
andava da 200 a 150 milioni di anni fa
i primi e umili sono entrati in scena
solo 7 milioni di anni fa erano sapiens
è a malapena risiede su questo quadrante
quindi faccio un ri set dell'orologio e
riparto 200.000 anni fa quando sapiens
entra in scena ci sono poi le diverse
all'evoluzioni umane quella cognitiva
poi quella agricola e quella industriale
ed eccoci subito arrivati agli ultimi
200 anni quelli moderni quali cosiddetto
illuminati dove troviamo musica e una
tale quantità di altre cose che devo
leggere dell'on
siamo un miliardo tanto per cominciare
c'è un rumore delle macchine a vapore
macchine che consentono di fare macchine
ancora più grandi il colonialismo la
fortwo mente dell'uomo
e i primi saccheggi del pianeta ci sono
le rivolte sociali bombe e fertilizzante
la grande guerra e l'esplosione
demografica a livello mondiale
siamo due miliardi arrivano gli anni
trenta con new york che compete con
londra e berlino
il primo dispiegamento di armi di
distruzione di massa seguito dalla
dichiarazione universale dei diritti
dell'uomo
il petrolio c'è materiale per la
plastica carburante per le automobili
cita tentacolari siamo 3 miliardi c'è
domanda e offerta produzione e consumo
di massa film gloriosi anni sessanta
un'esplosione di creatività
la società dell'usa e getta il primo
trapianto di cuore plastica ancora
plastica dappertutto pesticidi e
organismi geneticamente modificati
il freon e il buco dell'ozono sui viaggi
nello spazio il personal computer pac
man e supermario cene e mtv chernobyl
est e ovest nord e sud la cina in mezzo
l'africa dimenticata internet i mercati
finanziari
una ricerca della sostenibilità miniere
aperto la biodiversità foreste bruciato
reti globali il riscaldamento globale il
terrorismo globale 20 miliardi poli
l'acciaio auto march tra piante di testa
la vita virtuali siamo più di 7 miliardi
e della disuguaglianza tra questa donna
è questa qua
prima conflitto dopo conflitto emergenza
dopo emergenza disastro dopo disastri la
guerra dopo no scusate forse
[Musica]
può forse esagerato un po però è chiaro
che il nostro fare su questo pianeta
oramai alla forza pari a quello dei
grandi cataclismi naturali della
preistoria
adesso siamo noi la causa del
cambiamento climatico e anche senza
l'uso delle bombe atomiche facciamo
scomparire speciali i mali e vegetali a
un ritmo pari a quelle grandi estinzioni
di massa e per questo fa molto senza
chiamare i nostri tempi l'antropocene
cioè l'era dell'altro pose l'uomo un'era
che potrebbe essere ricordato fra un
milione di anni da uno strato di fossili
di varie creature misti con cemento e
radioattività di plastica
beh sapete forse non ho esagerato più di
tanto perché tutto quello che ha fatto
passare in rassegna si trova su internet
non su youtube i tanti filosofi studiosi
della nostra cultura hanno chiamato
proprio youtube una wonder camerin della
nostra epoca
infatti youtube fa vedere di tutto
rispecchia il caos a confusione in cui
ci troviamo no un vero pasticcio degno
del cinquecento e forse ci troviamo
ancora nello stesso pasticcio e non
siamo mai stati moderni come dice
qualcuno
ovviamente ci sono delle differenze tra
il 500 e adesso mentre allora le novità
venivano dal nulla
no da continenti sconosciuti adesso
vengono progettate da un apparato
scientifico tecnologico per un consumo
di massa
e mentre allora le novità erano delle
vere meraviglie
adesso le novità non meravigliano più
perché si soppiantano una dopo l'altra e
ci siamo abituati oramai che è tutto è
possibile
mancanza di meraviglia significa
mancanza di dubbio e di senso critico su
come operiamo su questo su questo
pianeta e rimaniamo incastrati in questo
modello consumistico che ha scommesso da
ogni tipo di valore tra non quello del
denaro che appiattisce la nostra cultura
umana che può portare anche alla
scomparsa delle nostra civilizzazione
sennò un'altra estinzione di massa
guerra io non posso cambiare il mondo ma
credo che il mondo possa essere cambiato
e per questo ho creato una stanza delle
meraviglie
vi ricordate di museum girasse
technology
ebbene io fondato di un centro così in
tecnologia un museo che parla
dell'antropocene e anche un po di
tecnologie per esempio fa vedere
un'opera che mette in luce una lampada a
incandescenza con una foto stampata con
l'inquinamento atmosferico stesso che la
foto fa vedere un paio di occhiali e qui
anche qui edifici spiegare tutto quello
che si vede ma adesso voglio provarci
questi occhiali sono chiari con questi
qui un oggetto molto semplice no fatto
da plastica e vetro
ma qui vince scritto qualcosa che adesso
non riesco a vedere perché ci vogliono
gli occhiali no ma so che c'è scritto
made in china e questo fa esplode questo
oggetto è in una cosa molto più
complessa si sarà disegnato più in
italia ma vedo gli operai cinesi che
l'hanno prodotto inquinando
l'aria e le acque della loro città vedo
le guerre nel medio oriente per il
petrolio materia prima per la plastica
poi vedo le navi che vanno dal medio
oriente in cina con il petrolio e poi
quelle che vanno da chen in italia con
gli occhiali e poi perché fatto unità in
cina perché la manodopera costa di meno
si allora siamo noi che guadagniamo
troppo sono loro che guadagnano troppo
poco e vedete tutto ciò fa di questo
oggetto una cosa una meraviglia che non
posso più votare facilmente via anzi mi
viene di metterlo su un piedistallo
insomma questo museo maps vuole essere
una macchina per guardare con lo scopo
di ritrovare la meraviglia e il dubbio
per far vedere come tutto è un po più
complesso rispetto a quello che ci fa
credere
il modello consumistico vuole sistemare
questo nostro caos andando offre
divisione della modernità tra natura e
società tra scienze artefatti valore e
facendo così si spera di scoprire nuovi
modi di vedere e di vivere il mondo modi
che possono essere la base per
affrontare i nostri grandi problemi
collettivi
voglio finire con un ulteriore del
pensiero è chiaro che un solo museo
rischia di avere poco impatto no
soprattutto che si trova a laveno
mombello qui vicino un altro l'anno
ma cosa succederebbe se ci fossero ci
fosse una rete di tali museion una rete
capillare un po come le nostre chiese
non ci è bastato solo san pietro a roma
per diffondere la dottrina della chiesa
no ci sono volute chiese cappelle e
pievi dappertutto e non basta solo tette
per diffondere le idee ci vogliono tutte
quelle di allora oltre al ma stiamo
anche pensando già una specie di matrix
e di questo stavo parlando con il mio
amico
grazie di questo stavo parlando con il
mio amico come il mio amico fabio
qualche mese fa e lui diceva beh bisogna
parlare con francesco e francesco p
papà francesco addirittura papa francese
ma vuoi dire usare le chiese come musei
infatti credo che sia bello per tutti di
entrare in una chiesa dalla luce
riverberante della città dentro per
spazi un buio e silenzioso dove la
frenesia si ferma ma oltre a poter
salutare il dio padre i suoi santi se
volete o riflettere sulla vita dopo la
morte perché non potersi fermare davanti
un opera una meraviglia che ci fa
riflettere sulla vita di oggi perché non
dedicare un altare alla nostra casa
comune come lo stesso papa francesco
chiama questo insolubile intreccio tra
natura e uomo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]